[Música]
el punto es el siguiente quisiera que
ustedes se pongan en mil 819
aproximadamente cuando el gran pintor
español francisco de goya y lucientes
consumido ya por la sordera consumido
por una decepción total frente a lo que
es la situación política que vive españa
en ese momento atormentado por la guerra
atormentado por la guerra civil
atormentado por la sangre atormentado
por la miseria que le toca haber
atormentado fue fundamentalmente por el
dolor y el asco se encierra en su quinta
del sordo en españa' y pintó una serie
de pinturas perdón por la redundancia
como esta que tienen ustedes en la
pantalla esta pintura se llama cronos
devorando a su hijo y es una alusión
concreta a lo que goya está sintiendo
ese momento cuando siente que una
sociedad está tragando pse a sus propios
hijos cuando esa sociedad
carcomida está devorando pse a sus
propios hijos
y esta imagen goya lo utiliza como una
especie de metáfora para decir aquí
tenemos un crono que es una sociedad
demente devorándose a sus propios hijos
casi dos siglos después la
extraordinaria antropóloga rossana
reguillo va a utilizar esta misma
metáfora no tanto la pintura sino como
cronos que cronos básicamente dentro de
la mitología griega es el dios que se
comía a sus propios hijos para evitar
que sus hijos tengan el poder pero en su
texto que se llama culturas emergentes
rossana reguillo dice hoy empezando el
siglo 21 estamos asistiendo a esta misma
imagen cuando una sociedad adulta está
comiéndose a sus jóvenes sin
posibilidades de darle a estos jóvenes
una una esperanza frente a los grandes
desafíos que tenemos como sociedad de
ahí que la intención de esta charla y de
estos minutos con ustedes no es darles
respuestas sino hacernos preguntas y
creo que la primera pregunta y la más
importante que tenemos que hacernos es
qué significa ser joven en este momento
que entendemos o qué es lo que debemos
nosotros comprender como el concepto de
joven si ustedes
hoy días en el ejercicio haganlo suban
el trufi vayan al mercado a comprar
pregúntenle a sus tíos hablen con
personas adultas y pregúntenle que
piensan y qué opinan de los jóvenes hoy
y les van a dar las siguientes
respuestas lo firmo
la mayoría de los adultos ve a los
jóvenes y te va decir los jóvenes en
este momento son muy apáticos no
participan de la vida política no
participan activamente de la sociedad
están encerrados en su mundo no son como
nosotros que luchábamos en las calles
por la democracia que luchamos en las
calles por un mundo mejor por paz y amor
los jóvenes ahora son apáticos ante todo
el problema político les van a decir que
los jóvenes son banales que cada vez
extienden más a entrar en el juego de la
cultura de masas y básicamente de
olvidarse de la realidad concentrándose
en su propia diversión en su propio
entretenimiento o les van a decir que
los jóvenes tienen una tendencia tal a
propasarse dentro del abuso de las
sustancias del alcohol de las drogas el
abuso de la criminalidad y por eso vemos
tantos jóvenes que constituyen las
pandillas y eso es lo que más o menos en
un gran porcentaje los adultos piensan o
por lo menos asumen que son los jóvenes
entonces es muy interesante preguntarse
eso por qué
si ahorita vinieron adultos y les dice
ustedes jóvenes son apáticos son banales
o tienen propensión a la criminalidad
que le dirían ustedes
como les responderían para mí sería muy
fácil y preguntarle esa persona y
decirle de qué joven estás hablando
estás hablando de un joven que vive en
la zona norte con todas las comodidades
que tiene acceso a internet todo el
tiempo que estudió en una universidad
privada o que se alimenta todos los días
tres veces o estás hablando de los
jóvenes que viven en condiciones
deplorables jóvenes que viven bajo
sistemas familiares que están destruidos
de que joven hablamos según los datos de
la cepal el 2018 el continente
latinoamericano es decir latinoamérica
tiene casi un 65% de población que es
joven es decir está entre los 15 y los
35 años lo que significa que
latinoamérica es un continente joven
fiesta vivimos en un continente hiper
productivo donde la mayoría de su
población está en edad de construir de
crear está en lo máximo de su fuerza
laboral y sin embargo es la misma cepal
la que informa que de esa mayoría casi
un 40 por ciento de esos jóvenes viven
en estado de pobreza en una
supervivencia en medios precarios y más
aún cuando casi el 10 por ciento de esa
pobreza es de extrema pobreza o
situación de calle situación de tratar
de sobrevivir el día a día entonces de
que jóvenes hablamos como una sociedad
adulta hipócritamente se puede dar el
lujo de creer que puede valorar a los
jóvenes a partir de criterios que son
absolutamente están lejos de una
realidad más compleja que la que
acostumbramos a ver el gran error dice
rossana reguillo es que las sociedades
adultas tienden a universalizar el
concepto de joven para los adultos los
jóvenes piensan igual todos los jóvenes
aspiran a lo mismo todos los jóvenes
tienen el mismo objetivo y eso se
traduce
en la incapacidad que tienen los estados
para generar políticas para jóvenes por
ejemplo el estado piensa que va a
mejorar la situación de riesgo que
tienen los codos de los jóvenes en el
consumo de drogas haciendo canchas
deportivas
lo que pasa es que a mí no me gusta el
deporte no me vale madre qué pasa si yo
tengo otro tipo de actividad como la
música por ejemplo como el teatro o qué
sencilla y llanamente tengo otro tipo de
visión con respecto al mundo y no me
interesa entrar dentro de esa lógica
entonces qué ocurre los adultos desde
los padres hasta el estado quienes nos
gobiernan consideran que los jóvenes son
una sola cosa que los jóvenes es como
una especie de masa uniforme que todos
van a tener la misma aspiración y todos
van a alcanzar a buscar lo mismo y de
ahí parte básicamente lo que ocurre con
los jóvenes en latinoamérica son
invisibles en este mismo momento estamos
llevando adelante nosotros un evento que
a mí me parece trascendental me parece
importantísimo me parece hermoso además
dónde está la cobertura informativa
dónde están los medios de comunicación
informando sobre esto dónde está la
sociedad adulta solidarizada o
mínimamente si quieren ustedes
compartiendo un momento en el cual los
jóvenes son
cuando uno considera que los jóvenes son
toda una sola cosa la sociedad lo que
hace es quitarles voz a las diferencias
no porque todo lo que es distinto a lo
que la sociedad espera de los jóvenes es
cuestionado no ese joven rockero al ver
ser satánico si me entienden todo
aquello que no encaja todo aquello que
está fuera de esas conductas y esas
normas sociales está sirviendo para ese
segundo otro punto los jóvenes son
criminalizados las diferencias de los
jóvenes son vistas con paternalismo no
hagan la prueba no no les estoy dando
ninguna idea pero piensen si ustedes van
a casa y le dicen a sus papás mira papá
he descubierto que estudiar no es para
mí yo quiero dedicarme a la música o
quiero hacerme crecer el pelo o dejar de
bañarme y sergipe
sus papás nos van a mirar con ternura y
les van a decir por hijito ya va a
madurar o van agarrar la chancla y te la
van a tirar pero esa es la reacción
adulta o sea no comprende que dentro de
los jóvenes puedan existir distintos
proyectos frente a la realidad frente a
la vida frente a los cambios y por lo
tanto distintos discursos a mí no me
preocupa esta situación sino me preocupa
el medio ambiente o me preocupa por
ejemplo la falta o la mirada
antropocéntrica que descuida a los
animales qué sé yo todas las
preocupaciones que tienen los jóvenes en
este momento que nosotros las
ninguneamos las invisibiliza mos
nosotros como sociedad adulta guardamos
ante los jóvenes un silencio absoluto y
por lo tanto ni el estado ni los medios
de comunicación ni las instituciones ni
la propia educación es capaz de incluir
a todas las diferencias que existen
entre los jóvenes
de ahí es importante que nosotros
entendamos que los jóvenes
latinoamericanos pese a sus diferencias
han tenido un historia en común una
historia en común que se materializa a
partir de los años 90 en un fracaso de
un modelo económico el modelo económico
que tenemos en latinoamérica esa
aplicación de un concepto neoliberal ha
fracasado porque ha fracasado porque no
se han solucionado los problemas
esenciales no tenemos mejoras en la
educación no tenemos mejoras en la salud
no tenemos mejora en el acceso al
trabajo todo lo contrario esta situación
se ha agravado todo lo contrario cada
vez es más pobre cada vez es más
precaria en salud en educación la
educación que es el tema que yo manejo
se ha concentrado en formar técnicos
pero ha dejado de formar estudiantes con
una visión humanista del mundo y por lo
tanto los jóvenes salen no con pericias
para manejar instrumentos técnicos pero
incapaces de comprender su entorno desde
perspectivas más amplias y encima todo
esto
lo que la cultura de masas impone o nos
vende tampoco contribuye mucho fíjense
en lo que pasa con el fenómeno de las
auto ayudas a los libros de autoayuda te
dicen que a ver tú eres la energía en ti
este el universo tú eres el que va a
buscar su propio futuro y tú le decís
usted está hablando de mí no pero eso es
una perdóneme porque lo único que
está haciendo es aislarte y está
diciéndote el resto te va a
el que está al lado tuyo es tu enemigo
por lo tanto en ti en ese individualismo
puro es que se sostiene toda la cultura
de masas y se sostiene por lo tanto un
instinto de vida criminal para el joven
en resumidas cuentas son los adultos los
que han genera una situación en la cual
un sistema fracasado ha generado una
crisis constante en la cual los jóvenes
tienen que asumir el desafío de ir con
la ley de la selva y básicamente si yo
les digo lo que pasa en europa por
ejemplo donde un joven sin trabajo tiene
la posibilidad de que el estado de
alguna manera lo mantenga un tiempo
hasta que consiga trabajo no es pues de
ciencia ficción para nosotros decirles a
ustedes no se preocupen porque mientras
se encuentres trabajo el estado te va a
ayudar
y nos cagamos de risa porque sabemos que
eso no es cierto porque va a depender de
nosotros y así cada vez cada vez no nos
encerramos en una sociedad de una si
quieren visión adultocéntrica que
desprecie invisibiliza o simplemente
ningunea las expresiones de los jóvenes
y encima encima les echa la culpa de los
males sociales incapaz de cuestionarse a
sí mismos los adultos como dice reguillo
no han optado por echarle la culpa a los
jóvenes de todo entonces qué opción les
damos como país a la gran cantidad de
jóvenes que pueblan que les decimos mira
este sistema no funciona aquí no tienes
oportunidad tu título no sirve para nada
porque nadie te va a dar trabajo porque
eres joven entonces ándate
y tenemos miles y miles de personas que
se van que emigran porque este país no
les ha permitido ejercer ni como jóvenes
y mucho menos incluirlos en espacios de
representación en sus discursos
entonces obligamos y empujamos a
nuestros jóvenes a que formen parte de
esa estadística de migrantes que va a ir
a buscar un sueño y posiblemente como
están las cosas jamás los encuentren
jamás los alcancen segundo empujamos a
los jóvenes en familias quebradas donde
las instituciones ya han perdido toda
noción de inclusión social y donde
nosotros a nuestros propios jóvenes les
decimos no encajas no perteneces pórtate
bien o vas a ser castigado todo lo
diferente lo obliga básicamente a ir a
identificarse con grupos
qué te dicen sabes que eres mi hermano
carnal de sangre te vamos a proteger
vamos a estar contigo y a cambio de que
nada tienes que vender tu alma al
no más y eso es lo que hace el
narcotráfico eso es lo que hacen las
pandillas
básicamente se apropian de un malestar
social y van captando a jóvenes y niños
en el accionar delictivo a fin de sacar
sus propios beneficios pero simplemente
entregándoles a los jóvenes lo que el
estado debería darles que seguridad que
es trabajo que es posibilidad de
ejercicio y sobre todo representación
así que ccoo ya en el fondo no estaba
pintando no una sociedad que se comía a
la propia sociedad yo coincido con
reguillo este cronos somos la sociedad
adulta ahora devorándose a sus hijos
comiéndose los poco a poco evitando que
sus hijos algún día
el poder le disputen el control le
disputen sobre todo la capacidad de
renovar discursos de mantenerse en esos
discursos y esa es la pregunta o esas
son las preguntas que hay que hacer se
hace dos días el mundo de alguna manera
conmemoraba un aniversario más del
fallecimiento de julio cortázar gran
escritor argentino a quien le hubiera
gustado mucho que se lo recuerde en un
evento con este como éste
o sea repleto de jóvenes y cortázar
tiene un éxito muy bonito dice un
cronopio pequeñito busca la llave de la
puerta en la mesa de luz la mesa de luz
en el dormitorio el dormitorio en la
casa la casa en la calle ahí se detiene
el cronopio pues para salir a la calle
precisa la llave de la puerta así que
qué llave necesitamos nosotros para
salir
qué es lo que van a hacer ustedes para
empezar a visibilizar esas diferencias y
para de una vez por todas como zeus y
como hades rebelarse contra el padre y
evitar que se los coman muchísimas
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]